here with a delicious and nutritious
recipe made with a staple in her pantry
is the author of to asia with love
and my other favorite book family
cookbook
um author and renowned food writer hedy
mckinnon
hi dr thanks for having me so hedy
what are you gonna teach us with your
beautiful
wisdom today i am so excited to be
sharing this recipe from to asia with
love
it is using this ingredient that i grew
up eating it's a chinese
fermented black beans these are not the
black beans you use in your
chili by the way so these have been
soaked do you want to start cooking
okay so what do we do first so we're
going to start off by just
mashing the black beans that are in your
bowl
and you're just going to get a thick
paste
okay that's amazing so we've got that
here so it doesn't have to be too much
it's not like mashed potato or anything
now we're going to add some aromatics so
we have some garlic
garlic throw that in
and some i've just using red chili red
pepper flakes but you can use fresh
chili
if you've got it i love spinach
yeah so do i and then i've got some
shouting wine which is going to add some
kind of nice a nice hummus flavor there
some soy sauce this is actually a
gluten-free soy sauce
i've got some olive oil here add that in
stylishly added
you're doing good guys and some sugar
and drew and dr oz you've just made your
own homemade black bean sauce none of
that jarred stuff
do you want to start with the beans i'm
going to turn my the heat on
yes please yeah you've got your seam
going
so i'm going to use you can use any oil
but i'm going to use olive oil today
because it's healthier
um i'm using a good quality good quality
olive oil which you can cook at high
temperatures so i'm just going to
pour that into my hot pan um
dr oz have you ever seen that list of
like
the eight oils that you should avoid
cooking with high heat yes a hateful
eight do you agree
disagree no i agree they oxidize the
damage
when you fry oils you're losing all the
benefit and you're creating all kinds of
compounds you can't predict why would
you do that to yourself
yeah i've really gotten much more into
olive oil
and coconut oil which is hard because it
really can flavor your food
can i have my beans yet yeah add your
beans in
[Music]
look at that go yes it's crackling now
oh i love that
so we're gonna get see it's um already
starting to
turn that beautiful shade of
vibrant green
okay so we've cooked these maybe a
minute
two minutes i mean just have a look at
them as soon as they start charring
but we want them bright green you don't
want them to go gray
so now i'm i'm going to put my sauce in
you can add all of the sauce or you can
add half i'm probably going to add about
half of the sauce
okay oh honey it smells so authentic and
layered and beautiful
i'm gonna dish mine up too just put it
on top of your rice if you've got rice
now dr oz how do you feel about rice
and like the gluten movement
and which a lot of people of course with
all sensitivities are absolutely celiac
intolerant
um but what do you think about you know
rice you know obviously since the
beginning of time
but now all these sort of gluten
alternatives you know if you truly have
celiac skip gluten
most people who skip gluten don't have
celiac and people who are
trying to trick their bodies doesn't
work very well if you try to make wheat
for example without gluten you lose the
stickiness of it
you've got to put chemicals in there to
recreate that experience eat the real
food
and if you can't eat gluten which i get
completely if you're gluten intolerant
eat foods don't have gluten in them
the beans don't have gluten right you
know just to just leave out the parts
that do
all right here well said i know
i'm like let me just ask the doctor
because there's nothing i love in the
world more
than beautiful rice and this just
looks like such a more satisfying dish
because it is
on top of the rice
[Music]
and it took three minutes i mean you
can't beat that
um three minutes teddy it has that
crunch
yes heidi i am
such a fan of yours your thank you
are as a cookbook collector as a
creator of a thing called cookbook club
your books are some of the most
interesting
unique and beautifully done that i've
ever seen
in my life i am such an uber fan oh
thank you so much
oh and before we go check out the sculpt
society's
amazing leg and bottom workout that you
can do right in your living room
we'll be right back thank you honey
megan group here from the sculpt society
app and today i'm sharing my hot tips
to sculpt your booty so let's get
started so first we're going to go into
a tabletop
if you find this is too much tension in
your back i always suggest clients go
down to a forearm
or both to keep a strong neutral spine
you're going to extend that leg straight
back squeezing that butt
pull that knee high into your shoulder a
little oblique action here
and then straight back my hot tip here
is if you want a little more
core action and you're a little bit more
advanced you want to turn it up a notch
extend that working arm front and back
this is really going to work your core
as well
as your touch